these are your worst nightmare
they are blood-sucking parasites that
can give you
all sorts of diseases so
how easily can a tick transmit disease
and what should you do if you're bitten
by a tick
we're here to help you understand the
tick
throughout the world there are an
astonishing 800 different species of
ticks
they all have four pairs of legs a small
head and a round body
and they're closely related to spiders
but where on your body are you most
likely to get bitten by a tick
ticks are most likely to bite you on
your groin an armpit
or other hairy regions they like
moist areas and it's not true that ticks
will fly onto you
they can't fly but they will cling to
blades of grass
and latch on when you walk by them then
they crawl
up your body so if you're out in nature
it's best to wear long sleeves and
trousers
and it may not look cool but pulling
your socks over your pants
could save you a lot of trouble later
ticks suck blood like other bugs and
insects but what makes them so dangerous
is they transmit more diseases
ticks aren't born with diseases so it's
only once a tick takes blood from an
infected animal that the tick could
carry that disease
and then it can pass the disease on when
it has its next meal
that would be you if a tick bites you it
creates a wound
and sucks your blood and in return they
leave their infected saliva in the wound
you're welcome these tiny arachnids can
carry
a range of diseases one of the most
common
is lyme disease each year about 300
000 americans report having lyme disease
and numbers seem to be increasing caused
by the borrelia bacteria
symptoms can include fever rash fatigue
and muscle aches nerve damage and facial
paralysis can also occur
and in severe cases it causes
inflammation of the spinal cord
or the brain so now that we've scared
you enough
what can you do if a tick bites you make
sure you're thorough when checking your
body
ticks aren't quick biters like
mosquitoes if they bite you
they can stay hooked onto your body for
up to 10 days
if you do find one try removing it from
as close to
your skin as possible if you keep it in
a sealed container it can be sent for
testing to find out if it carried any
diseases
the best thing you can do is to get
medical help as soon as you can
you may think it's unlikely you'll get
bitten by a tick but due to global
warming and climate change
their natural habitat is expanding ticks
are even encroaching
on our urban areas so parks and walking
trails aren't so safe either
and it's better to be safe than sorry
when it comes to ticks
they can suck your blood and give you
deadly diseases
that's what ticks do and that's what
makes them
crazy creatures
you